well Republican leaders say the new tax
code will save millions of Americans
money but it could cause problems for
charities nonprofits received about
three hundred and ninety billion dollars
in donations last year but by some
estimates the new code could drop result
in a drop in twenty billion dollars in
donations a year Jan Crawford is at a
charity that feeds the homeless in
Washington with why people are concerned
the new law could mean less giving Jan
good morning
well good morning for organizations like
so others might eat here in the nation's
capital the end of the year tends to
meet a spike in donations that's because
people see charitable contributions is
the way they can cut their tax bill but
next year that might change with
temperatures in Washington dipping below
freezing
these Salvation Army volunteers are
hitting the streets handing out food to
those in need
organizations like these across the
country rely on donations in 2017 as
many as 30 percent of taxpayers could
reduce their tax bill by itemizing
deductions making it possible to write
off charitable donations but under the
new law around 90 percent of taxpayers
are likely to choose the new doubled
standard deduction instead eliminating
the tax incentive to give to charity
there'll be 30 million fewer people
itemizing their taxes United Way CEO
Brian Gallagher says his organization is
able to serve 60 million people a year
thanks to more than 3 billion dollars in
charitable donations the average
contribution by United Way donor in the
u.s. is about 350 dollars and those are
the donors that now will have no
incentive less incentive additional
changes to the estate tax could
contribute to a further decline in
charitable giving each year we're really
not sure what's going to happen but
Eileen Heisman of the national
philanthropic trust says such a decline
would force charitable organizations
nationwide to cut back on services for
hospitals it's about serving people who
are sick you know for daycare centers
soup kitchens I mean if you can imagine
10% of the budgets of all the charities
you know
States perhaps being affected that could
really be substantial no nonprofit
leaders for quick to point out that most
people don't give to charity just to get
a tax break but even a four or five
percent increase in donations could have
a big impact on community organizations
that already are struggling to stay
afloat
Dana Jan thank you very much sort of sad
to think of some of those charities that
may lose out just because of the loss of
a deduction tracking the people that
need it most
yeah exactly